voir
bienvenue dans génération nous sommes
ici à la cité internationale
universitaire de paris au collège franco
britannique pour notre deuxième émission
de génération europe
notre thème aujourd'hui le citoyen
européen
existe-t-il vraiment nous en parlerons
avec nos étudiants européens qui sont là
mais aussi avec notre invité rama yade
bienvenue à vous tous alors d'emblée
j'ai envie de vous poser cette question
est ce que vous vous sentez sur tout
citoyen européen ou plutôt nationale
lisa je me sens tellement mais je me
sens aussi européenne donc par exemple
quand comme j'ai vu ici en france quand
je parle avec tes français et je suis la
seule au monde
je me sens quand même assez un monde et
je vois les différences un peu entre moi
et les français ou ceux des autres
nations mais quand je parle avec les
gens qui ne viennent pas de l'europe ou
aussi quand je suis avec un groupe du
rhdp 1 surtout quand je suis avec un
groupe de jeunes de mon âge par exemple
domicile par exemple à l'un des singles
en europe une absence qui sont plutôt
national ou européen
chloé alors je me sens justement plus
européenne parce que mon père y ma mère
chypriote et je suis né à paris donc
serait que je pour moi c'est plus facile
de dire europe
j'ai trois métiers un passeport qui est
doux de la république de chypre en fait
et dessus alors à ce que ses écrits
cteur et donc non il l'europe n'est pas
mentionné
depuis quand il est passé en 2006
c'était deux ans après que chypre a
adhéré à l'union européenne est
normalement est-ce que ça apparaît
surtout les passeports par exemple johan
toi tu es génial je me semble plus
européen que d'espagnols qui te sens
plus européen que tania paribas espagne
chine c'est une étape plurinational ma
nation c'est le catalan alors nous
sommes nous font partie d'une union
c'est l'arpn alors je me réveille pas
avec tous les jours avec l'âge je suis
européen mais quand si tu me demandes je
suis
oui je lisais la motivation c'est je
suis une citoyens européens et les
français sont français ou sont européens
je pense que c'est vraiment quand on
quand on quitte le continent
enfin notamment je passe y est ainsi
quelques un voyage un peu au canada ou
aux états unis
là on se rend compte vraiment que ya une
culture européenne et que on est vu par
les autres comme le vieux continent
comme et plus même que j'ai en étant
juste français ou du parisien où ça va
tout ses intérêts européens dans le
regard des autres mais pas dans tout car
à toi moi je suis français mais
j'aimerais j'aimerais me sentir plus
européen mai sur le passeport qu'est-ce
qui a écrit l'union européenne
république française et si tu compares
par rapport à l'espagne la différence
c'est qu'il n'ya pas république
espagnole
ouais ça c'est de la prime est différent
un bonheur espagnol s'est créé un énorme
une analyse psychologique des états les
états ça veut dire que la france est
mieux dans sa peau se sentent de plus en
moyenne que les espagnols effectivement
oui j'ai surtout fait que enfin l'union
européenne apparaît avant la république
française ce à ses fins symboliquement
je veux dire ça a quelque chose
d'important que les deux semaines sur se
mettre sur le même plan et antonello
alors toi tu embrasses port il n'est
heureusement je n'ai pas de passeport
parce que j'ai jamais voyagé hors de
l'europe et donc j'ai jamais eu besoin
d'un passeport et peut-être maintenant
que tout le monde 2 sort son passeport
je me rends compte que ça pourrait être
une expression de ce que l'europe à
bâtir six mois comme italien avec ma
carte d'identité italienne qu'en plus
elle est bleue à la trace de tous les
autres et italiens qui est marrant parce
que je viens d'une région autonome qui
est la vallée d'aoste tout en narrant
près du mont blanc où il ya le jambon
d'aoste n'a rien à voir pour les
français on ne vient pas de la recherche
de gens vont pas chez toi exactement le
genre on danse
les français donc c'est tout à fait une
région autonome et bilingues dont ça
fait rire parce que seulement quatre
identités il écrit républicain italien
la république italienne
en l'absence du français et du coup j'ai
jamais eu besoin de faire un passeport
pour voyager en europe
ça peut être c'est symptômes du travail
que l'europe a fait allez je vous
propose de revenir tout de suite aux
fondamentaux sur le sujet on va parler
de qu'est ce qui définit le citoyen
européen je vous propose tout de suite
le reportage de thierry scharff mise en
image par hugo nicolas c'est l'essentiel
il faut bien le reconnaître la
construction de l'europe s'est jusqu'ici
surtout préoccupés d'économies ceci
étant dit depuis le traité de maastricht
de 1992 le citoyen européen est entrée
de plein droit dans les textes
communautaires et citoyens de l'union
toute personne ayant la nationalité d'un
état membre la citoyenneté européenne
s'ajoute donc à la citoyenneté nationale
d'ailleurs la définition juridique du
citoyen européen n'existe nulle part
elle résulte d'une somme de textes issus
de divers traités et d'arrêt de la cour
de justice européenne de tout ça ressort
tout de même quatre grands droits
spécifiques du citoyen européen
premièrement la libre
circulation au sein de l'europe réservez
au départ aux seuls travailleurs le
droit de séjour c'est aujourd'hui
élargie à tous au moins de façon
théorique car dans les faits tous les
citoyens européens ne jouissent pas de
la même souplesse partout en europe
deuxième droits du citoyen européen le
droit de vote et d'éligibilité aux
élections municipales et européennes
mais pas question de devenir maire ou
adjoint non mais troisième droits du
citoyen européen
la protection diplomatique et consulaire
une façon de mettre à égalité tous les
européens à l'extérieur de l'europe
enfin quatrième droits du citoyen
européen le droit de pétition devant le
parlement européen et de recours au
médiateur européen un million de
citoyens issus de plusieurs pays peuvent
inviter la commission à soumettre une
proposition d'actes juridiques à l'union
sur un sujet particulier un droit tout
nouveau mis en place en avril dernier la
citoyenneté européenne
un chantier à benthami la citoyenneté
européenne un chantier vient de dire
thierry charles
qu'est ce que tu en penses j'ai laissé
un chantier actuellement je pense que
l'une identité ça se crée aussi parce
qu'on a les mêmes droits on a les mêmes
conditions de vie les mêmes conditions
de travail et c'est vraiment pas le cas
actuellement d'un pays à l'autre les
conditions de vie peuvent changer
les salaires varient énormément et donc
du coup je pense que l'identité
s'inscrire entre par sa part des progrès
sociaux est ce pas le cas actuellement
lorraine moi je me sens très européenne
aussi parce que je suis né aux pays bas
le parti faire les études en angleterre
et je pense que quand on est européen on
a toutes ces possibilités qui s'ouvrent
et que dans certaines régions du monde
c'est pas forcément possible et je pense
que le chantier européen et enfin
personnellement quasiment on va
continuer à parler de la citoyenneté
européenne est ce que ce sens citoyen
européen ou pas est ce qu'on l'a et
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on l'ait je vous
propose qu'on accueille tout petit notre
invité aujourd'hui qui rama yade
ça a un sens pour vous d'être citoyen
européen
je le suis sur le papier je me suis
quand je suis hors des frontières
européennes
mais c'est pour moi c'est encore en
chantier en construction vous avez
proposé d'être députée européenne ya
cinq ans l'europe vous rattrape
maintenant est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la façon de se sentir
européen a changé sur les cinq dernières
années
chantier il se fait il semaine je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux
je pense qu'on peut faire mieux parce
que depuis en cinq ans bon il ya le
traité de lisbonne qui est entré en
vigueur
mais ça s'est passé dans des
circonstances assez difficile puisque
les boîtes nationaux n'étaient pas
forcément favorable quand il ya eu vote
et quand il n'y a pas eu de vote c'est à
dire qu'on est passé par le parlement là
les contestations de des europhobes et
eurosceptiques aurait été quand même
forte sur le thème parce qu'on a rejeté
le traité de 2005 vous passez par la
fenêtre via le traité de lisbonne
donc il ya quand même encore un travail
de pédagogie à faire d'information je
sais pas s'il est tout le monde le sait
mais 2013 c'est l'année du citoyen
européen voilà il y aurait fallu qu'il
se passe des choses que le citoyen
européen s'élève pour cent du début 2014
maintenant pour la côte est ont
peut-être qui vaut même est en tout cas
pour l'union européenne c'est l'année du
sein européens s'appliquent à quoi bon
on sait pas justement parce que rien ne
s'est vu peut-être que je sais en fait
mais rien de ses vues et c'est ça le
problème c'est pas tant est-ce que
citoyen européen existe que comment on
le fait vivre comment on le met en avant
comment il existe dans l'espace
politique économique sociale culturelle
donc c'est ça peut se faire peut-être
sur laquelle il faut travailler moi je
serais pour qui m c'est pas moi à tv5 ou
en wifi européen pour qu'on ait les
infos qu'ils viennent d'abord de
l'europe et un rognon ouais mais voyez
il faut vous mettre plus en avant soirée
puis il faut aller dans le canal je suis
pas combien loin derrière public sénat
pour avoir lieu et puis les élections
européennes par exemple c'est le cas
depuis 119 mais on devrait voter le même
jour peut-être pour donner un sentiment
d'appartenir voilà à une même aussi
autre chose c'est-à-dire que est-ce que
vous commenciez à l'évoquer sur comment
s'est construit un petit peu le citoyen
au t1 mais est-ce qu'il n'est pas tout
simplement juste défini par rapport au
droit et à la loi oui ça qu'il ya une
sorte de manque de visibilité là dessus
et les institutions européennes
justement sont quand même assez mauvaise
là dessus pour expliquer ce qui se passe
est clair en fait tout simplement
mais c'est vrai que enfin de citoyenneté
c'est pas que des droits ceux ci une
culture c'est un sentiment d'appartenir
à une communauté
puisqu'on parle de nationalité
européenne et si on avait un petit peu
plus loin écoutez ce que vous propose
tout de suite notre partenaire de
technikart
olivier manu je crois que ce qui est
clair pour beaucoup de gens c'est que
l'identité européenne c'est d'abord des
valeurs communes la liberté la libre
circulation des personnes et puis la
démocratie un jour nous aurons peut-être
un passeport européen nous tous une
identité juridique européenne mais à
quoi ça lui servirait vraiment d'avoir
une identité européenne
à une époque où on voit qu'on
s'intéresse de plus en plus en même
temps local au terroir bref à ce qui
fait qu'on lui une petite partie de
l'europe et pas un vaste ensemble ils
parlent d'une identité européenne et
savoir ce que ça veut dire dans un monde
qui devient de plus en plus locales etc
mais ce mouvement là il se fait quand
même à côté d'un autre mouvement qui est
assez important qui s'appelle la
mondialisation et
et c'est là dessus que l'identité
européenne elle est vraiment importante
on a hissé à l'extérieur de l'europe
c'est pour exister dans une
mondialisation qui devient de plus en
plus compliqués à assumer pour une
france qui reste compétitive mais qui a
quelques problèmes vis-à-vis de la chine
et puissances émergentes et l'union
européenne
c'est quand même le premier marché
mondial 500 millions d'habitants de
consommateurs aussi et si on veut
exister à mon avis dans cette course là
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut oui donc ça
protège en effet face à la globalisation
et la mondialisation il n'empêche que
face au régionalisme on le voit bien
avec notre catalan enfin bien avec notre
val d'aoste tient valdôtains mal de
temps je les dis pas et souvent que in
de rien est ce que c'est pas aussi
l'europe c'est pas aussi la solution
face à la nation à laquelle peut-être
vous ne croyez pas tant que ça l'italie
tu y crois je crois plus à l'europe
évidemment parce que quand même l'état
nation italien des issues historique n'a
jamais existé par contre je me perçois
valdes autant je suis contente de mon
autonomie de ma région
et pourtant j'ai plus pour moi c'est
plus simple de me concevoir européenne
mais que italien c'est le même que moi
je me sens le catalan après si tu es
favorise une échelle je suis catalan je
suis le barcelonais jeu catalan je suis
européen que johan les barcelonais il
n'y a pas ni j'ai confiance plus avec le
avec l'europe occupée avec l'espagne
c'est intéressant parce que le
régionalisme n'est pas forcément une
un débat contre l'européanisme exact
c'est complémentaire
c'est même une complicité exact en ce
sens où tous les mouvements régionaux
ont pu se protéger grâce à l'europe et
donc les régionalistes comme les
européens s'entendent sur le dos des
nations finalement moi par exemple moi
je me suis je me sens français dans le
sens où parce que je sais que tous les
français ont les mêmes droits je reviens
un peu sur cette histoire de droits
sociaux mais ça me semble important
quand même le jour où tout ça ce sera
peut-être harmoniser vers le haut
peut-être qu'il y aura une identité
européenne
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est que là on est rassemblée si on est
tous à peu près étudiants il ya des gens
qui peuvent venir en erasmus et tout
mais c'est pas la majorité des gens et
c'est pas la mort la majorité des jeunes
notamment pour lire la secousse parce
que qu'on soit français espagnol et tout
pour partir en erasmus il ya des bourses
etc
mais c'est jamais suffisant oui et ça
c'est une chose de ravello d'actualité
parce que le ministre de culture
l'éducation de l'espagne des seniors
roberte il voulait quitter la bourse à
les étudiants erasmus voulait à cause de
la crise la solution s'est arrêté c'est
une chose très très mauvaise je ne peux
pas aller en erasmus invité à paris une
ville un peu cher leur ça veut dire si
je n'ai pas de dettes pour étudier pour
être ici il n'y a pas de sens de faire
ça tu ne peux pas le faire
un enfant est né l'autre moi simple je
pense ma région je serai absolument pas
ici parce que l'état italien je pense
que du point de vue de l'instruction
s'est mis encore pire que le tabac comme
l'état espagnol donc même moi je suis
pas en erasmus si je fais un double
diplôme en droit italien et français
et j'ai reçu rien de l'état et de mon
université italienne
donc c'est seulement grâce à ma région
que je suis là étaient parents aussi
aimé parent et vient oui mais ça montre
aussi que ça dépend des milieux oui
louis ouais mais c'est justement ça
c'est enfin c'est un vrai problème parce
que c'est avec les aras mu s'est ouvert
à 3% je crois des étudiants en france
est absolument fin c'est absolument rien
surtout quand on sait que enfin le
budget au niveau européen est en train
de saper complètement
les bourses etc c'est vraiment le
fondement d'une découverte des autres
pays de création d'un vrai dans vrai
sentiment d'appartenance quoi c'est par
là qu'on construit le citoyen européen
évidemment oui on parle d'erasmus on
parle des programmes pour les jeunes
pour justement leur permettre de se
déplacer et d'étudier dans d'autres pays
quid de la mobilité dans le travail
aujourd'hui en europe et entonner l'eau
est allé enquêter il a fait le tintin
reporter à son tour il a été guidé par
thierry scharff on suit cette petite
pérégrinations dans paris à la recherche
d'informations sur la mobilité dans le
travail mais noté rené antonello
étudiants erasmus au droit français et
italiens la cité universitaire
internationale
il connaît bien c'est là qu'il vit je
suis pas seulement italien mais je viens
de laval et danseurs très attaché à sa
région ottonello est aussi un catholique
pratiquant qui sert régulièrement la
messe à notre-dame
étudiant d'europe
c'est simple mais pour ceux qui veulent
travailler
allons voir si la mobilité de l'emploi
est garanti par le droit européen dans
la réalité et malgré la crise les
européens bouchent très peu c'est un
sport de paris rendez vous avec
catherine de wenden spécialiste des
questions migratoires
c'est un élément de la citoyenneté
européenne qui prend beaucoup de retard
par rapport à beaucoup de droits et
jusqu'en 2004 3 % seulement des
européens
travailler dans un autre pays européen
que le leur
ce qui veut dire que les européens
profitent et peut finalement de cette
possibilité de s'expatrier dans un autre
pays européen
ceux qui vivent déjà en européen et en
travailleurs européens à l'intérieur de
l'europe ce sont les plus qualifiés et
non contrairement aux idées reçues ce ne
sont pas les femmes de ménage bulgare ni
même le plombier polonais qui constitue
le plus gros des troupes des migrants
européens
mais avoir des diplômes ne garantit pas
de trouver un job de niveau équivalent
juliana est plutôt chanceuse venu
rejoindre son amoureux qui a été muté à
paris elle a décroché un cdi en trois
mois mais elle qui était agent
territorial d'une petite ville du
piémont a dû accepter un emploi de
vendeuse chez moi c'est possible à paris
parce que
il y a de travail je crois que c'est
important de
d'être un peu adaptable peut-être on ne
trouve pas à
toujours le travail qu'on me fasse des
annonces pour moi c'est ça en italie je
t'ai ans technicienne maintenant je
changer complètement de demain ça c'est
importante peut-être pas le voile on
voit donc giuliana que tu as rencontré
anthony laup parce que ça montre que la
mobilité européenne est si évidente que
ça théo
oui donc on a entendu dans le reportage
que seulement 3 % des européens
travaillent à l'étranger
on peut dire seulement 3% mais on peut
dire 3% c'est déjà pas mal mais 3%
effectivement ça dépend c'est moi
j'adore toujours la vision positive en
général optimistic si tu peux le
regarder avec un avis négatif
et donc c'est seulement le 3% ou tu peux
le regarder avec nos vies positive à ma
question tu trouves ça que mon positif
positif
évidemment les qui pensent que ça va
évoluer tu penses que je pouvais en
italie où on fera
ma question personnelle je vais
travailler je pense que je voudrais
rentrer dans ma région vallée d'aoste
avec les chèvres les vaches parce que
moi j'adore ma région mais avec tous ce
bagage culturel et surtout cette
ouverture d'accord avec cette volonté de
rentrer chez soi rama yade qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire finalement de se dire
que on se déplace pour aller voir
ailleurs mais là on est bien chez soi
quand même ça prouve que en fait la
citoyenneté européenne est quand même un
privilège un privilège sur le plan
politique dans la mesure où ben on est
dans un continent qui finalement malgré
ses difficultés présente certains
avantages
il vaut mieux être européen de trot
sortie 102 pays où les droits de l'homme
sont bafoués
mais en même temps
c'est un privilège son plan économique
aussi on n'est pas européen par hasard
on est européen parce qu'on a les moyens
de sortir son pays d'aller ailleurs
quand on regarde le cas de la france
mais c'est tellement difficile de passer
on le voit pour quand on propose des
emplois dans la région de la côte et à
chômeurs voilà c'est pas en état et
kouassi 6 2 naciri qui voit là un emploi
parce que c'est un autre département
notre région et quand on est un
ressortissant d'un petit village je lui
dis village à côté sur l'étranger donc
vous imaginez l'europe interne et le on
va retomber retourner dans le monde du
travail mobile et on y revient juste
après
tiens brome
ce rallye de ramper l'agrément petit
avec l'europe pas besoin d'aller très
loin pour exploiter la misère de son
voisin surtout par temps de crise c'est
le cas de travailleurs portugais
embauchés dans le languedoc par un
patron d'une exploitation viticole
appliquant le niveau de salaire
portugais j'ai travaillé jour dès la
semaine j'avais pas se décourager et
j'ai fait cinq six et 12 13 14 ans avec
des jours 500 euros soit l'équivalent
d'un smic portugais la parade des fiches
de paie déclarant à mille temps une
pratique répandue mais tout à fait
frauduleuses petite visite à la cgt une
première pour entonner l'eau qui a pu
s'essayer un nouveau nick
le syndicat français dénonce l'émergence
de nouveaux travailleurs européens low
cost rendue possible par certaines
failles de la réglementation européenne
c'est le cas par exemple des
travailleurs détachés un salarié par
exemple qui vient travailler en france
et dont le contrat a été signé ailleurs
qu'en france pendant deux ans 24 mois il
est possible que les cotisations
sociales que paye son employeur soit
celle du pays d'origine de ce salarié
donc on arrive à des différences on va
dire de coût salarial global de 30 à 40%
pour moi c'est de la libre concurrence
totalement faussée et donc quelles
qu'elles euros pour reconstruire
est ce que c'est une europe avec du
dumping social ou bien c'est une europe
avec une harmonisation vers le haut des
droits pour les salariés à ce que vous
avez l'impression que créer ainsi la
mobilité dans le travail l'a favorisé
pour certains c'est finalement créé des
travailleurs low cost jules je pense
pour ce qu'ils ont fait cette europe là
oui il ya un autre exemple que les
travailleurs détachés
c'est pas qu'on utilise en parce qu'elle
y est pour rien mais l'allemagne par
exemple est en train de passer des
partenariats avec la grèce par exemple
pour faire venir des trains et des
jeunes travailleurs grecs des jeunes
diplômés qui vont travailler avec les
salaires minimums de la grèce
et ça effectivement ça crée de la
concurrence entre les travailleurs des
différentes nationalités enfin on ne
peut pas d'un côté pleurer qu'il n'y a
pas d'identité européenne que les gens
sont eurosceptiques et d'à côté en fait
construire quotidiennement la
concurrence entre les jours entre les
citoyens européens
on sait que les modèles économiques de
tous les pays européens
mes hommes sont différents qui sont pas
dans le même état l'allemagne vient de
passer un smic qui était déjà une
réussite sociale mais malheureusement on
n'est pas un état fédéral
ils aient voté ou lait pas voter non pas
encore en soutien aux merkel a promis
juste content juste j'ai pas dit que
enfin du jour au lendemain que là qu'on
allait mettre un smic amis 1200 euros
par mois dans tous les pays en revanche
ce qui est possible c'est par exemple
fédéral c'est ce qui est possible en
revanche c'est un salaire par exemple
proportionnelle au salaire minimum du
pays en slick proportionnelle au salaire
minimum du pays donc disons un smic 20%
au-dessus du salaire minimum
du pays dans chaque pays ça c'est
possible et ça déjà c'est déjà une
avancée qui permet d'éviter la
concurrence etc
et la deuxième chose c'est que quand on
traverse travail dans un pays ils paient
les charges sociales du pays et pas les
charges sociales de son pays d'origine
est ce que on est en train de créer des
travailleurs locaux je pense qu'il ya
deux solutions en attendant un jour une
harmonisation d'abord sur la question de
l'élargissement
parce que c'est ça en fait d'en
connecter des pays à peu près similaire
en terme de poids économique ça allait
et quand vous plus vous élargissez à des
pays où les différences sociales et
réglementaires sont tellement fortes et
bien vous êtes confrontés de plus en
plus à ce problème donc je pense que
pour l'élargissement faut peut-être
aller moins vite et deuxièmement
travailler sur la croissance dont le
travail est rare
ben voilà vous avez une concurrence
entre les pauvres parce que c'est à ça
qu'on ait réduit
c'est à dire que les pauvres à des pays
du plombier polonais ou autres qui sont
confrontés à nos pauvres de chez nous et
qui rafle la mise
pardon de tenir un vocabulaire un peu
donc on prend militants mais c'est tout
c'est l'employeur qui va essayer à
travers les différentes réglementations
en les contournant en jouant du droit
parce qu'il ya les avocats qui
permettent de faire ça et bien ce que le
droit j'ai tout permettre de voilà de
profiter de cette situation
donc à un moment donné plutôt que de se
partager un travail qui se fait de plus
en plus rare entre des gens qui sont
pauvres
eh bien il faut peut-être poser la
question de la croissance et c'est là
encore une fois que moi j'ai
interpellerait volonté les autorités
monétaires européennes qui ont fait des
choix qui peut être un moment s'imposait
de lutte drastique de contre l'inflation
mais la contrepartie de ça ça a été une
croissance bas niveau donc low cost
j'aimerais qu'on termine par la question
là de notre partenaire atlantico on va
parler maintenant de la question de la
solidarité
est-ce que ça définit pas aussi le
citoyen européen
il ya quelque chose qui était vraiment
marquant pendant la crise de la dette
depuis 2008 c'est que ni les allemands
ni les français n'avaient envie de payer
pour les déficits des grecs aux états
unis qui sont aussi une zone monétaire
commune avec le dollar
le massachusetts ne se pose jamais la
question de renflouer les caisses du
kentucky ou l'alabama s'ils en ont
besoin jusqu'à présent la citoyenneté
européenne elle était beaucoup
construite sur du juridique sur du
respect des règles comment est ce qu'on
fait pour créer une citoyenneté où il
est un peu plus d'identité un peu plus
de solidarité lorraine
théo auxquels réagir je pense que de
manière paradoxale la crise a réussi à
nous faire réaliser que nous sommes
responsables des uns des autres qu'il
faut s'occuper aussi de l'économie
grecque portugaise espagnole
même si c'est difficile ça crée
l'identité européenne parce que ça va
pas créer du repli selon toi sacré de la
solidarité la crise oui enfin non je dis
pas que ça crée t et créer de la
solidarité je crois que ça a créé la fin
on a réalisé une conscience une gueule
et la conscience européenne on a réalisé
que finalement on était tous les les uns
aux autres et qu'il fallait qu'on
apprenne à la travaillant sont liés ou
dépendants j'aurais même selon toi j'ai
vu une reportage en espagne qui parlait
de la solidarité comme la nouvelle
colonialisme l'allemagne il voit une
pays avec beaucoup de problèmes et il
est mais il contrôle sept pays
alors je pense que oui ils existent il
existe déjà une citoyens européenne il
faut qu'il existe mais avec une
solidarité sa neuvième but monétaire
fait solidaire et désintéressé jules je
pense que les seuls à se sentir citoyen
européen actuellement c'est les élites
en fait mais pour une raison qu'en fait
elles sont toujours sentis européenne
les élites même à l'époque des
monarchies avant les états-nations elle
se sentait déjà européenne et le jour où
en revanche le reste de la population et
enfin en vrai l'entière population se
sentira citoyenne européenne c'est le
jour où l'europe sera synonyme de
progrès social démocratie ce qui n'est
pas du tout actuellement le cas
en concluant sa marina l'esprit davis au
début de l'unification italienne
on utilisait cette phrase maintenant on
a fait l'italie il faut faire les
italiens
je pense de ne pas faire une arnaque
ronis mme allard utilisant maintenant ça
veut dire qu'on est en train de faire
l'europe mais on
dire que maintenant on a fait l'europe
il faut faire les européens et ça c'est
la chose la plus la plus difficile des
martiens tenait le rama yade au vu de
tous ces échanges et de ce que vous
pensiez déjà avant la citoyenneté
européenne
vaste programme on va se voir mais ça
prendra du temps mais je pense qu'on
finira par y arriver
d'abord parce que par rapport au reste
du monde
les européens ça existe aux yeux des
autres un reste à ce que ça existe
à nos yeux à nous on est à la veille
d'élections européennes en france et on
nous prédit que le premier parti de
france
c'est le front national qui le parti le
plus de robes la france moteur un pays
fondateur de l'union européenne moteur
du couple franco-allemand donc pas
n'importe quel pays où le premier parti
de france
ce serait le parti le plus europhile
c'est quand même inquiétant je me pose
sur la question de savoir pourquoi ceux
qui critiquent l'europe envoie à
bruxelles mais gens qui veulent avoir
les europhobes il faut envoyer des gens
européen convaincu mais mes critiques
merci beaucoup à rama yade pour le
prochain numéro de génération europe on
se retrouvera et justement on posera la
question de quelle europe
voulez vous la voulez vous social
politique ou économique c'est au
prochain numéro